date d'ailleurs qui s'appelle christian
qu'ils étaient très gentils lé record
avec son mari pour tout vous dire avait
pas reconnu moi c'est ce que c'est que
la notoriété à bavay elle avait reconnu
mon compagnon bon
qui commence à faire un coup de vieux
mais grâce à vous arrive ça commence
ainsi vu ses ventes ayant maintenant
c'est fini je le dis à tout le public
m'attend j'accepte les photos
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je redis je l'adorent il vit les choses
est moins drôle il s'en fout il j'aime
bien ça rigole j'aime bien j'aime bien
j'aime beaucoup ce n'est qu'on a croisé
la seule et unique personne qui pouvait
me reconnaître mois
en france parce que bon c'est comme
comparer un cheval de course avec un
poney shetland
assez mignon un mois quand je me balade
avec daniel
tous les morts la
reconnaît
et donc ouais c'était d'être assez sympa
c'était si vous êtes déjà timide a
retenti à quelqu'un de connu quand on
est tous les deux connu c'est fou moins
un mois je sais pas encore à quoi pas si
c'est connaît maintenant c'est
franchement si steph quand même pas
pleurer
aujourd'hui quand je me balade dans la
rue tous ne sont actuellement que mes
enfants c'est que mes enfants me
connaissent thürler que c'est vrai sont
mignons
c'est vrai cc c'est compliqué à moi je
franchement honnêtement aujourd'hui
c'est ça fait trop peu de temps que je
suis médiatisé donc franchement là c'est
laurent tout le monde le reconnaît tout
le monde s'intéresse à lui et moi je
suis à côté puis je perds fois
honnêtement c'est comme ça que ça se
passe aujourd'hui
on s'en souvient longtemps sa marque
professionnelle
ouais
ou est-ce qu'au bois de boulogne vous ai
déjà
connu sous le nom de gi la goulue rouaix
[Applaudissements]
c'est fou hein
bravo vous êtes vous êtes magnifique
d'émotion déjà sorti quelqu'un de connu
a parfois il est sûr qu'avec la vie
flafla bon ben
c'est la nasa libre ça c'est une panacée
c'est parce que vous restez jamais au
même niveau donc forcément il y en a un
qui va monter l'autre qui va redescendre
et c'est le moment où il ya des
problèmes ah ouais c'est ça être
pagaille et on a un peu d'écho quand on
fait ce métier forcément ouais ça dépend
à près de 2 du caractère ça puisque par
exemple je pense honnêtement que laurent
n'aura jamais aucun problème avec le
fait de me voir monter au contraire je
pense qu'il sera à te retourner mais
comme il est prêt ou d'un peu de temps
je pense que dans long terme de
caractère sa personnalité fait que ce
que tu dis là il ya vraiment de problème
d'ego on est prêt et parce qu'en fait
ils y passent au lawrence et
vise par exemple si vous sortiez qu'avec
quelqu'un tu perds s'élèvent çà vous
poserai pas de trophée bringault à non
non non vous dit rien mais n'accorde
qu'un jour vous avez quelqu'un
d'extrêmement célèbre avec un bloc est
quelqu'un vient bien pour un autographe
ou une photo et ne vous reconnaît pas
mais reconnaît par orange mois due to b
c'est de vivre apprend foot al anon mais
je m'en fous ne savent pas quoi ça
n'arrive pas à notre niveau
mais pas à l'international ils servent à
rien il va il va miami
bah oui 5 ha non dit des conneries
[Applaudissements]